So now that you've written your first Python program, you might
be wondering why we need to invent new languages like Python to
program computers and spend all the effort into learning a new
language, rather than using some language like English or Mandarin that we
already know. And there lots of reasons for that. That natural
languages like English and Mandarin are great for people who grew up
speaking them for day-to-day conversation. But there are many reason that
they wouldn't work well for programming computers. The first one is ambiguity.
Natural languages are inherently ambiguous. Different people can interpret
the same sentence to mean many different things. When
we program computers, the computer needs to interpret that
program. And we want to make sure that the computer
interprets the program the exact same way that the
programmer, who wrote the program, intends for it to
be interpreted. So here's an example of the kinds
of ambiguities that come up in natural languages like English,
and we'll do this in the form of a quiz. So the question is, would you rather be
paid $100 weekly or biweekly? So these are the choices, you can
prefer to be paid $100 weekly; you can prefer to be paid $100 biweekly. It
depends, or you are an altruist and you don't like to be paid at all